[Música]
y
en la vida de las personas hay fechas
que son simbólicas son como anclajes
puntos de referencia a lo largo de
nuestras vidas una de ellas son los
cumpleaños solemos recordar los
cumpleaños recientes y también solemos
recordar los cumpleaños pasados por
ejemplo los de la escuela primaria eran
toda una negociación una negociación que
arrancaba al comienzo del año escolar
negociación con nuestros compañeros sino
que cambiase esta figurita no te invito
negociación con nuestros padres yo
quiero hacerlo en casa no nene está el
pelotero está la plaza porque la casa
que la destruyen todas negociaciones con
nosotros mismos chocotorta o bizcochuelo
de dulce de leche
bueno esto no es para todos yo soy del 4
de enero
así que los que saben que son de enero
nunca una fiesta con amigos todo el
mundo de vacaciones encima hermano mayor
de 4 un cumpleaños para navidad
cumpleaños reyes y a otra cosa mariposa
la cuestión es que por añoranza por
deseo recordamos esos cumpleaños pasados
pero pocas veces pensamos en el
cumpleaños del futuro
acaso ustedes pensaron cómo celebrar su
cumpleaños número 45
suena lejos verdad miran
en un ecosistema como el nuestro donde
hay ciertas cuestiones de saneamiento de
seguridad de acceso a la salud de cada
cuatro personas que llegan a 80 años
tres van a llegar a 85 2 van a llegar a
los 90 y una de ellas va a celebrar su
cumpleaños número 95 una persona que hoy
cumple 70 años apenas tiene entre el 2 y
el 4 por ciento de chances de morir ese
mismo año cuando hace 50 años atrás era
por arriba del 40 por ciento
qué nos pasa a los que somos los que
venimos un poquito más por detrás los
que estamos alrededor de los 50 años
tenemos el 50 por ciento de chances de
celebrar ese cumpleaños número 95 y por
ejemplo mi hijo que es un millennial que
anda por ahí el probablemente llegue a
celebrar su cumpleaños número 100
que me cuentan
para algunos le suena muy lejano verdad
y ustedes dirán miran a hablar de la
longevidad no no es algo nuevo ya cuando
hicieron casi 50 años antes de cristo
escribió de senectud fue un pionero no
solo porque habló de longevidad sino
porque además le dio el protagonismo a
marko catón que en ese momento en la
obra tenía 85 años un adelantado
sin embargo
hoy lo que estamos viviendo es diferente
hoy estamos viendo lo que a mí me gusta
llamar nueva longevidad a una visión
optimista una visión amable una visión
360 de todos esos años que el desarrollo
nos regalo
mira no sólo hay hoy más personas
mayores hoy en argentina para que usted
se den una idea
el 12 por ciento de las personas de
nuestro país tiene más de 65 años el 16
por ciento tiene más de 60 aquí mar de
plata más de plata es el núcleo urbano
con mayor grado de envejecimiento
poblacional 26 por ciento de los
habitantes más de plata tienen más de 60
años que me cuentan
no solo cada vez hay más personas
mayores sino que cada vez vivimos más
hoy el pico de la expectativa de vida
está en japón en las mujeres 87 88 años
los hombres un poquito por detrás
hace 50 años atrás en mexico se vivía
hasta los 57 años en promedio hoy se
vive hasta los 77 pero también se está
viviendo con nuevos roles en argentina
aquí son más de 6 millones y medio de
fotos de las personas mayores se
imaginan si se organizan que me cuentan
simplemente esos roles saben qué grupo
está creciendo más en facebook
sabe quiénes son los usuarios mejores
calificados en plataformas nuevas de uso
como über como herb y anv y las personas
mayores pero también esta nueva
longevidad nos está enfrentando a nuevos
desafíos
la diversidad
vivir más hace que cada vez por ejemplo
tengamos nos preocupemos más por el
cuidado las personas con deterioro
cognitivo el cuidado es uno de los
grandes desafíos que hoy tenemos pero
además se está viviendo con más
intensidad
cada vez conocemos más personas que
deciden empezar nuevos emprendimientos
realizar
el viaje de su vida
retomar cuestiones que quedaron
pendientes como mi alumno samuel samuel
tiene más de 60 años haciendo un kiosco
aquí a 200 metros y él en una
oportunidad me dijo es que sabe diego yo
estudié medicina en la plata y por
determinadas circunstancias de la vida
tuve que abandonarla y hoy lo tengo de
estudiante en la escuela superior de
medicina
y también conocemos cada vez más
personas que deciden separarse del amor
de su vida y otras en cambio que deciden
enamorarse eso es la nueva longevidad
están modificando transformando la
realidad en la que vivimos
saben algo
en china hay más personas mayores de 60
años que toda la población de rusia que
son más de 142 millones de habitantes en
eeuu las personas mayores controlan el
70% de la economía doméstica en muchas
ciudades de europa hay más bastones y
más sillas de rueda que cochecitos de
bebé
en japón se venden más ropa interior
absorbente que pañales de bebés
eso es lo que está pasando bueno ustedes
pueden decirme si claro eso en esos
países y que hay del nuestro
aquí en argentina en promedio entre
siete y ocho de cada diez personas
mayores son propietarias de su casa de
su terreno del apartamento donde viven
entre el 15 y el 18 por ciento realizan
trabajo voluntario cuidando a los nietos
yendo a un hospital hacer compañía
trabajo voluntario
muchos de ellos femenino el 70%
imaginen una huelga de estas mujeres un
trabajo que no es remunerado que no es
reconocido que es invisible
se convierten en re distribuidores de
riqueza sí sí porque la mayor parte de
ellos ya tienen sus necesidades básicas
satisfechas ya partieron sus hijos del
hogar
entonces así las personas mayores son
además consumidores son productores y
son re distribuidores de riquezas porque
esa persona con la pensión que muchas
veces es el único ingreso regular que
tiene su hogar distribuye a la hija o al
hijo para el supermercado al nieto para
la universidad y de esa manera da un
cierto una cierta tranquilidad a esa
familia
como les dije están cambiando las reglas
de juego pensaron cuántos cumpleaños de
95 hay en todas esas cifras que le di
hablar de la nueva longevidad
no es simple al contrario es complejo
cuando hablamos de simpleza y de
complejidad me gustaría hay que traer
como referencia a john locke john locke
era un médico y un filósofo vivió en el
año 1600 en el reino unido- y fue lo que
sea lo que hoy llamaríamos un disruptor
un tipo de avanzada tuvo el tupé de
oponerse al paradigma de ese momento que
era el paradigma cartesiano se acuerdan
ese de primero pienso luego existo bien
se dicen que influyó a rousseau voltaire
a kant y que sus principios llegan hasta
la mismísima constitución de los estados
unidos de norteamérica
por cierto ruso fue el que dijo en la
juventud se aprende sobre la sabiduría y
en la vejez se la disfruta volvamos a
john locke john locke decía al contrario
de los cartesianos
que la mente era como una tabla rasa con
un pizarrón vacío y que la experiencia
iba generando el conocimiento de esa
manera y esto fue lo que lo hizo más
conocido él hablaba de las ideas simples
aquellas ideas aquellas percepciones que
nos llegaban a nosotros a partir del
olfato del gusto de la vista también del
placer y del dolor
y las combinó con las ideas complejas
aquellas que además de estar basadas en
las ideas simples son las que iniciación
de la abstracción la conjunción la
experiencia pero por sobre todas las
cosas de la reflexión por eso es tan
difícil pensar en la longevidad
porque es abstracto pero además porque
se necesita de autorreflexión
en chile está humberto maturana humberto
maturana es un célebre biólogo y
pensador chileno que hace un tiempo
atrás en un reportaje dijo al contrario
de lo que muchos creen el futuro les
pertenece a las personas mayores bueno
tiene 90 años así que por algo lo debe
decir
lo que es interesante es que maturana de
su formación biologicista dice que a
través del lenguaje de las
conversaciones se crea la experiencia y
a través de eso nosotros nos vinculamos
con la cultura con el amor con los
sentimientos y que sin lenguajes sin
conversar no hay conocimiento y eso me
parece que es apropiado porque es lo que
nos está faltando a nuestra sociedad
conversar darle visibilidad a las
personas mayores a los viejos y a las
viejas eso es lo que hoy nos está
faltando aunque seguramente muchos de
ustedes se piensen inmortales por favor
levanten la mano los que tienen menos de
30 años
estos son todos los inmortales porque
antes de los 30 años que a uno le hablen
de longevidad de viejos de viejas de
cumpleaños número 95 no existía pero
tranquilos todo pasa después los 30 yo
le aseguro que esto empieza a volverse
una realidad
yo creo que acá una reflexión no 75 años
con sus cómplices de banda juntan casi
300 años de vida arriba del escenario
en cada concierto corre entre 13 y 15 km
tiene ocho nietos le diríamos abuelito
mick jagger y sus amigos y muchos otros
más lo que están haciendo es
transformando la realidad están
redefiniendo el concepto de vejez y para
esto no hace falta hacer un rolling
stones
y frameworks iframe lo conocí hace unos
años cuando le propuse conversar para lo
que fue mi primer libro en ese momento
tenía 95 años y me dijo sabe que doctor
venga después de las 3 de la tarde luego
porque esta es obra trabajo me dice
efraín en ese momento había competido en
cuatro campeonatos mundiales de
atletismo como ven van unas cuantas
medallas lo interesante de efraín es que
empezó a correr después de los 80 años
harriet thompson norteamericana en su
juventud una concertista de piano
clásico
harriet fue la primera mujer en
completar la maratón de 42 km a los 91
años después de los 90
arrieta thompson también comenzó a
correr después de los 80
esto es muy interesante porque no se
pregunta qué hace que estas personas
sigan adelante
qué es lo que hace que pudiendo estar
sentado como mick jagger en la playa en
la playa de subir la propia convengamos
lo está todavía dando conciertos que
hace efraín porque arriet thomson empezó
a correr pudiendo correr 510 k no se fue
los 42
que hace que samuel pudiendo estar
disfrutando de sus nietos se está
trabajando y está estudiando medicina
eso es la pasión que se siente por la
vida
y la pasión tiene un motor que es la
curiosidad es el descubrimiento como
cuando de chicos queríamos saber qué
regalos había dentro de semon yo de ese
papel que venía o cuando queríamos saber
si finalmente nuestro amiguito que
invitamos por nuestros padres y que no
queríamos que viniera iba a aparecer o
no
entonces esa curiosidad es lo
interesante aprender descubrir curiosear
hace al proyecto de vida ac a llenar de
vitalidad todos esos años que el
desarrollo nos regalo
ya que es muy fácil algunos decidirán
emprender ese viaje algunos decidieran
enamorarse algunos decidieran contemplar
la vida en algún lugar otros decidirán
irse de vacaciones con sus amigos y por
qué no porque no lo que es interesante
de todo esto es que tenemos que darle
lugar a las personas mayores porque van
a cambiar las reglas del juego cuando
hay muchas veces me preguntan yo suelo
decir miren el caso de las personas
mayores es el caso donde uno dice el
futuro llegó ya están aquí ya son
mayoría y van a seguir modificando las
reglas de nuestra sociedad de nuestra
comunidad por los próximos 30 años
se dieron cuenta de algo
porque aquí hay un problema los viejos y
las viejas son los otros
porque tercerizamos porque ponemos la
vejez fuera si después de todo cuando
nosotros nos vayamos de acá todos vamos
a hacer cinco horas más viejos y viejas
que cuando entramos pensaron eso y
cuando nos despertemos mañana en la
mañana vamos a tener un día más vivido
vamos a hacer más mayores
por eso quizás yo los invito a que esté
quizás a la noche con se estén acostando
mañana cuando se están despertando
quizás este sea un buen momento para
imaginar para pensar cómo les gustaría a
ustedes celebrar su cumpleaños número 95
bienvenidos a la nueva longevidad
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]